Do I want choice over my own body?
Yeah. Like,
do you wanna control what happens to your body
or do you want the government to control what happens to your body?
I wanna control my own body.
Yeah, you do.
Can I ask you a quick question on reproductive freedom?
Like, all about it.
Okay. You're all about it?
Yeah. Okay, great.
Do we support reproductive freedom?
Yeah. Yeah.
Why do we support it?
Cause people should be able to choose what they do with their bodies.
Pop off! You don't know what reproductive freedom is?
It's the freedom for your body to have your own choice over your body.
Reproductive freedom. Oh, absolutely.
And do we support reproductive freedom?
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, we do.
Why do we support it? Guess a woman's right.
Absolutely. Pop off.
Queen. And we support reproductive freedom. Okay. Yes.
You're registered to vote?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Pop off! Pop off!
Pop off! How do we feel about reproductive freedom?
Yes. Our choice. Yeah. Thank you.